THE COMIC LEGEND 80 YEARS
OLD NOW A CONVICTED FELON.
DANA?
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, BRIAN.
THANK YOU SOLVE.
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE HAS TRIED
THESE TYPE OF ACASES.
THE REAL DETERMINING FACTOR
WAS THIS IDEA OF THE OTHER
CRIMES EVIDENCE AND ALLOWING
OTHER PEOPLE TO COME IN AND
TALK ABOUT IT.
>> YEAH, AND PROSECUTORS AND
WE USE THAT KIND OF EVIDENCE
IN CASES CALLED PRIOR BAD
ACTS.
SORT OF LIKE THE COLLOQUIAL
TERMINOLOGY EVIDENCE OF
OTHER PEOPLE COMING FORWARD
TO SAY THAT THE DEFENDANT
ACTED IN A WAY SIMILAR WITH
THEM IN TERMS OF LIKE MODUS
OPERANDI RAN DAY THE WAY
THEY BEHAVE.
IN TERMS OF BILL COSBY IN
THIS CASE THEY HAD TO LOOK
FOR OTHER EVIDENCE OF
VICTIMS AND WITNESSES TO
COME FORWARD BE VERY SIMILAR
IN NATURE TO THIS PARTICULAR
CASE AND WITH THIS VICTIM
ALLEGED HAPPENED TO HER
WHICH IS PATTERN AND
PRACTICE OF DRUGGING FOR THE
PURPOSES OF COMMITTING A
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND IN THIS CASE, IT WAS
ALLEGED THAT BENADRYL WAS
USED TO TRY TO PUT HER OUT
UNDER -- AND MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT.
BECAUSE, WHEN YOU ARE IN A
CASE LIKE THIS AND SOMEBODY
DOES THIS AND YOU PREY ON
ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL, YOU USE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BECAUSE
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO REALLY
RECALL, RECOLLECT, OR BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY AGAINST YOU
OR PERHAPS EVEN IDENTIFY
WHEN YOU HEAR OF CASES
SAYING LIKE ROOFY IN
COLUMBUS, ET CETERA.
PARTICULARLY HEINOUS BECAUSE
YOU ARE PICKING ON A
VULNERABLE VICTIM TO DO THAT
IN THE HOPES THAT THEY WON'T
BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY YOU AND
IN THE HOPES YOU WILL BE
ABLE TO DO IT AGAIN SO YOU
CAN PREY ON MORE VICTIMS.
ONE OF THE THINGS IN THIS
CASE, BILL COSBY WILL BE
IDENTIFIED AND ASSESSED AS A
SEXUAL PREDATOR.
THEY WILL DO AN ASSESSMENT
AND PRESENT THAT TO THE
JUDGE AT THE TIME.
SO ALL THOSE OTHER PIECES OF
EVIDENCE AND INFORMATION
THAT CAME FORWARD THEY WILL
PUT THAT FORWARD TO
DETERMINE WHETHER HE SHOULD
BE CATEGORIZED AND WHETHER
HE SHOULD REGISTER AS A SEX
OFFENDER.
>> Dana: AT 80 YEARS OLD.
>> Dana: OTHER QUESTION FOR
YOU AND TAKE IT AROUND THE
TABLE.
WHEN HIS LAWYERS SAY THEY'RE
DEFINITELY GOING TO APPEAL,
DO YOU THINK THAT THEY WOULD
TRY TO APPEAL ON THE GROUNDS
ABOUT THIS JUDGE AND HIS
DISCRETION OF ALLOWING THIS
EVIDENCE IN?
>> YES.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A BIG
PRE-TRIAL, A HEARING AND YOU
BRIEF THE MATTER TO SAY THIS
IS WHO WE WANT TO BRING IN
THEY TRIED TO BRING IN 14
WOMEN TO COME FORWARD.
THE JUDGE SAID I WILL ALLOW
THESE BECAUSE THEY ARE
PROBATIVE VERSUS TOO
PREJUDICIAL TO THE
DEFENDANT.
BECAUSE YOU REALLY HAVE TO
BALANCE THAT IT'S REALLY
RIPE FOR APPEAL FOR SOMEONE
TO BRING THAT FORWARD.
THIS HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT
AS PROSECUTORS I HAVE DONE
AS PROSECUTING SEXUAL
ASSAULT CASES.
REALLY FOUGHT HARD TO GET
THIS TO BE EVIDENCE ON THE
BOOKS BECAUSE IT IS SO
COMPELLING.
AND IN A CASE LIKE THIS
WHERE YOU DIDN'T HAVE D.N.A.
OR DIDN'T HAVE A PERCIPIENT
EYEWITNESS THERE TO SAY WHAT
HAPPENED TO HER IT'S HER
WORD AGAINST HIS.
THAT'S WHY THE OTHER
EVIDENCE IS COMPELLING TO
SAY WAIT A SECOND, SOMEONE
IS WILLING TO TAKE A STAND
AND TAKE AN OATH AND TELL
YOU SAME TYPE OF THING
HAPPENED TO THEM.
SOME OF THESE WOMEN WERE
PRECLUDED FROM HAVING
JUSTICE IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL
CASE BECAUSE THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS HAS RUN.
THEY WERE STILL THERE TO
TELL THE TRUTH
CROSS-EXAMINATION.
THAT WILL BE THE LINCHPIN OF
HEZBOLLAHER ROW'S APPEAL
WHICH TWO YEARS TO COME TO
LIGHT.
>> Dana: REMIND EVERYONE HE
IS NOT GOING TO JAIL THAT
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
>> NO.
HE IS OUT ON BAIL NOW.
PRETTY MUCH THE HOUSE, TOOK
AWAY HIS PASSPORT.
BECAUSE THEY SAY HE CAN BE A
FLIGHT RISK.
WHEN YOU THINK OF POLANSKI
OR HARVEY WEINSTEIN SOMEONE
WITH MEANS AND RECOURSE THAT
CAN CHARTER A PRIVATE JET
AND TAKE OFF AND NEVER BE
HEARD FROM AGAIN.
THE JUDGE MADE SURE THAT
WASN'T GOING TO HAPPEN IN
THIS CASE.
>> Dana: JUAN TURN TO YOU
FOR A COMMENT OR A QUESTION
FROM KIMBERLY.
>> COSBY IS SOMEONE I KNOW
PRETTY WELL.
AND, YOU KNOW, TO ME, COSBY
AND, YOU KNOW, TO ME, DOSBY
AND, YOU KNOW, TO ME, DOEBY
AND, YOU KNOW, TO ME, DOESY
COSBY'S GUILT LESS IN
QUESTION BECAUSE IS HE
SOMEONE WHO NITTED THAT HE
WAS BUYING QUAALUDES, NOW AN
ILLEGAL DRUG FOR THE PURPOSE
OF PARTYING.
AND TO GIVE THEM TO WOMEN.
AND THEN THE QUESTION WAS
WHETHER WHETHER OR NOT THAT
KIND OF THING WOULD BE
ALLOWED AND IT WAS ALLOWED
IN BOTH TRIALS THAT WERE
HEARD.
THE DIFFERENCE IN THIS ONE
AS KIMBERLY WAS SAYING IS
YOU HAD THE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY THAT CREATED FOR
THE JURY THE IMPRESSION OF A
PATTERN OF ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR.
AND I THINK THAT WHEREAS
THERE WAS AN ATTEMPT TO
UNDERMINE ANDREA CONSTAND,
THE PRINCIPLE PERSON HERE
CHARGING COSBY AS SOMEONE
WHO WAS A CON ARTIST IN THE
WORDS PLAINTIFF COSBY'S
DEFENSE ATTORNEY.
WHO WAS SIMPLY TRYING TO
MAKE MONEY OFF A VERY RICH,
FAMOUS MAN.
HERE CAME PEOPLE WHO SAID,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I WAS HOPING THAT HE WAS
GOING TO BE A FATHER-FIGURE.
THAT HE WAS GOING TO HELP ME
WITH MY CAREER.
DID I NOT UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS WAS WHAT HE WAS AFTER.
AND, IMPOSSIBLY, ONE OF THE
MOST CHILLING MOMENTS FROM
THE TRIAL, THERE WAS A YOUNG
WOMAN WHO WAS 17 AT THE
TIME.
HER NAME WAS CHILLAN LASH
SHAH.
SHE SAYS IN OPEN COURT YOU
REMEMBER ME, DON'T YOU,
MR. COSBY.
IT WAS LIKE OH MY GOD.
SHE WAS 17 AT THE TIME.
AND SHEAR SHE IS NOW STARING
HIM IN THE FACE AND SAYING
IT.
THAT'S PRETTY COMPELLING IF
YOU ARE SITTING THERE AS A
JUROR AND SAY, YOU KNOW,
WHAT IS SHE GETTING OUT OF
THIS?
SHE IS NO CON ARTIST.
REMEMBER, IN ADDITION, COSBY
HAD PAID $3 MILLION TO
CONSTAND IN A CIVIL CASE.
SO, TO SOME EXTENT HE HAD
ADMITTED SOME CULPABILITY ON
THAT LEVEL.
I JUST WANT TO CLOSE ON THIS
THOUGHT, DANA, HE WAS
AMERICA'S DAD AS YOU SAID IN
THE OPENING.
THE REASON THAT I KNOW HIM
SO WELL IS I WAS WRITING A
BOOK ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE
WAS SAYING TO THE BLACK
COMMUNITY HEY, YOU KNOW
THERE ARE DIFFERENT WAYS TO
LOOK AT SOCIAL PROGRESS AND
WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
WHY AREN'T WE TAKING A STAND
AGAINST DRUG DEALERS AND SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT HOLDING
BLACK FAMILIES TOGETHER.
WHY DON'T WE SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT OUR RESPONSIBILITY IN
TERMS OF HIGH RATES OF
VIOLENT CRIME?
AND IT WAS SO INTERESTING
THAT THE JUDGE IN THE FIRST
CASE, MAYBE BEFORE THE FIRST
CASE SAID I'M GOING TO ALLOW
IN ALL THIS EVIDENCE ABOUT
COSBY BECAUSE HE THINK HE IS
SUCH A MORALIST.
SELECT TEMPERATURING OTHER
PEOPLE.
IF HE SAID IN DEPOSITION HE
WAS BUYING QUAALUDES, LET IT
MORALIST.
IT CAME BACK TO BITE HIM BIG
TIME.
>> Dana: GREG, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU HAD A QUESTION FOR
KIMBERLY OR WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT ANYTHING IN
PARTICULAR.
>> Greg: I GUESS EVERYBODY
HAS KIND OF COVERED THE
ANGLES THAT YOU WOULD
EXPECT.
IF I HEAR THE PHRASE
AMERICA'S DAD AGAIN, YOU
KNOW REMEMBER THESE ARE
FICTITIOUS CHARACTERS.
REAL PEOPLE PLAY THOSE ROLES
AND SOMETIMES THEY ARE NOT
GOOD PEOPLE.
EALWAYS KIND OF GO WELL WE
ARE SO SURPRISED.
IF YOU LOOK AROUND IN
HISTORY AND LOOK AT A LOT OF
ENTERTAINERS.
A LOT OF THEM DO PLAY
WHOLESOME CHARACTERS.
JIMMY IN ENGLAND A BIG
ENTERTAINER OF CHILDREN AND
TURNED OUT HE WAS DISGUSTING
MOLESTER.
I HAVE A SIDE QUESTION THAT
I'M JUST CURIOUS.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE COSBY
SHOW?
SOMETHING THAT WAS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
SHOWS EVER IN SYNDICATION.
YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU
WATCH THE NAKED GUN AND OJ
IS IN IT, YOU CAN'T REALLY
WATCH IT THE WAY YOU USED TO
YOU WATCH IT WHEN YOU WATCH
THE COSBY SHOW WHEN YOU ARE
LOOKING AT IT, IT CHANGES
THE WAY YOU LOOK AT
SOMETHING.
I WONDER IF THAT'S JUST A
SHOW THAT KIND OF JUST GOES
AWAY.
>> Dana: SAID IN MY EAR ONE
STATION ALREADY CANCELLED
IT.
I'M NOT WILD, JESSE, ABOUT
TAKING JURY VERDICTS AS
POLITICAL STATEMENTS BECAUSE
I THINK JURY VERDICTS ARE
BASED ON EVIDENCE OF A
CRIME.
BUT, IT'S SORT OF INEVITABLE
TODAY THAT THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> Jesse: IF YOU LOOK AT IT
IN THE CON TESKTS ME TOO
MOVEMENT.
GREG HAS TALKED ABOUT THE
STRATOSPHERE OF GUILT.
VERY CLEAR BILL COSBY IS ON
THE FAR END OF STRATOSPHERE
IS HE IN THE HARVEY
WEINSTEIN SITUATION BECAUSE
AS YOU SAID THE PREDATORY
TYPE BEHAVIOR, THE QUAALUDES
AND MIXING THE QUAALUDES
WITH ALCOHOL IN A GROOMING
PROCESS OVER A PATTERN OVER
THE COURSE OF SINCE THE
160S, ACTUALLY STILL PENDING
A CIVIL LAWSUIT IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AT THE
PLAYBOY MANSION WHERE HE
ALLEGEDLY MOLESTED A TEENAGE
GIRL THERE AT THE PLAYBOY
MANSION.
SO THAT'S STILL PENDING.
SO, YOU KNOW, HE IS LOOKING
AT A PRETTY TOUGH NEXT
COUPLE YEARS.
WHEN YOU SEE SOMEONE -- AS A
KID IT'S BEWILDERS BECAUSE I
GREW UP WITH COSBY AND
TALENTED PEOPLE WITH DARK